dieser bedeutet für mich eine gewisse
zukunft aber die ist sehr ungewiss im
moment gibt keinen der eine prognose
abgeben würde
christoph kolbow 52 jahre solo
selbständige diese industriehalle in
düsseldorf war seine zukunft messen
firmenevents rund 50 veranstaltungen
waren über das jahr geplant er hätte
hier für die technische sicherheit
gesorgt einnahmen für ein ganzes jahr
weggebrochen wegen corona
neuerdings hat christoph kolbow zeit für
gartenarbeit die hat er normalerweise
nicht solo selbständige das sind etwa
taxifahrer fotografen oder
fitnesstrainer
sie sind selbstständige ohne eigene
angestellte fünf monate ohne arbeit eine
harte zeit für ihn ehefrau daniela und
die beiden söhne danken und dallas
das geld wird knapp die familie lebt
mittlerweile von ihren ersparnissen
10.000 euro mussten sie bereits
aufbrauchen
im oktober wird auch der rest weg sein
nur so können die kolbus lebensmittel
und offene rechnungen bezahlen
meistens habe ich dass ich das alles was
ich mir erarbeitet habe dass mir das
zwischen den fingern zerrinnt
und na ja das was ich mit leidenschaft
mache seit 30 jahren dass ich das nicht
mehr tun kann
mittlerweile musste er hartz 4
beantragen
[Musik]
was hat es für sie bedeutet den schritt
zu wagen und hat vier zu beantragen
katastrophe
so
doch ne sekunde keine perspektive wie
hilft der staat den über zwei millionen
solo selbstständigen eigentlich denen
die sogenannten sofort und
überbrückungshilfen den selbständigen
denen durch corona große teile ihrer
einnahmen weggebrochen sind
so wie christoph kolbow für die
soforthilfe gibt es insgesamt bis zu
9000 euro für drei monate die
bedingungen des bundes das geld darf
nicht für lebenshaltung wie einkäufe
oder miete ausgegeben werden es ist
ausschließlich für betriebskosten etwa
lager- büro- oder firmenwagen um mehr zu
helfen haben manche bundesländer deshalb
die soforthilfe ergänzt etwa nrw hier
waren zumindest 2000 der 9000 euro auch
für die lebenshaltung vorgesehen
[Musik]
geld fast nur für betriebskosten die hat
christoph kolbow kaum und so hat er wie
viele solo selbständige zwar 9000 euro
auf dem konto darf sie aber eigentlich
nicht ausgeben
denn alles was sie nicht als
betriebskosten belegen können müssen sie
zurückzahlen
sie haben das geld dennoch ausgegeben
aus purer not statt staatshilfe neue
schulden und allein in der krise
das ist für mich noch die diese fragen
mich nicht nachdenken was du november
ist
die hilfsmaßnahmen helfen vielen
selbständigen nicht kritisieren experten
etwa das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung in einer studie aus
dem juni darin wurde die lage der
selbständigen analysiert von massiven
umsatzeinbußen und einkommens rückgängen
bei selbstständigen ist die rede und
dass die ersparnisse bei vielen nur noch
für wenige monate reichen würden wir
treffen einen der verfasser der studie
alexander kritik aus man kann schon
sagen diese pandemie trifft die
selbständigen ganz besonders wer ein
bisschen auf die zahlen schauen rund 60
prozent aller selbständigen auch alle
solo selbstständigen haben
umsatzverluste zu verzeichnen und
einkommensverluste
ein großer teil von ihnen hat
totalausfälle gehabt als sie sind
sozusagen auf eine null umsatz
runtergefahren rechnen sie jetzt
pleitewelle die anstehen könnte bei den
selbständigen also ich rechne später zum
herbst mit einer größeren pleitewelle
denn für viele selbstständige ist es ja
auch so dass die umsätze nicht auf das
vorkrisenniveau zurückkehren
für einige bedeutet das auch dass sie
eben gar nicht aus der verlustzone
heraus kommen eigentlich soll das
jobcenter menschen helfen die ihre
arbeit verloren haben
in der korona krise sollen sie nun auch
selbstständigen helfen die normalerweise
einen job haben und davon ganz normal
leben können so will es die
bundesregierung selbständige werden im
kern so behandelt wie ganz normale hartz
4 empfänger aber sie haben ihren job ja
gar nicht verloren sondern brauchen
schlicht schnelles krisen geld wie genau
funktioniert dass die kriterien zum
beispiel bei einer familie
es wird zunächst der bedarf berechnet
etwa miete heizung und ein fester geld
satz für die lebenshaltung
diese kosten werden nun mit dem
einkommen aller familienmitglieder
verrechnet nur wenn der bedarf größer
ist als das einkommen besteht ein
anspruch der haken selbst von einem solo
selbstständigen alle einnahmen
wegbrechen bekommt er eventuell kein
hartz 4
etwa dann wenn der ehepartner noch genug
verdient welche erfahrungen haben
selbstständige mit diesem verfahren
gemacht um das herauszufinden haben wir
in einem aufruf solo selbständige
gebeten uns ihre erfahrungen zu
schildern
das ergebnis über 100 zuschriften aus
ganz deutschland zwar sind einige
zufrieden und beschreiben das alles
einfach und schnell gegen die große
mehrheit klagt jedoch über komplizierte
langwierige anträge etwa dass sie 150
seiten papier beim jobcenter eingereicht
haben oder über formulare die im
vereinfachten antrag explizit nicht
gefordert waren
fazit beim jobcenter freundlich und
hilfsbereit in vielen fällen aber auch
bürokratisch und mit penibler
vermögensprüfung die ist ja eigentlich
nicht geben soll
von den über 100 solo selbstständigen
die uns geschrieben haben bewerten 80
prozent die ihre erfahrung mit dem
jobcenter negativ
komplizierte anträge das
arbeitsministerium schreibt uns dazu
trotz vereinfachte prüfprozesse muss
zumindest nachgewiesen werden über
welche einkommen der die antragstellerin
verfügt andernfalls wäre die höhe der
leistungsansprüche auch gar nicht zu
ermitteln über mengen und umfang der
erforderlichen unterlagen können
aufgrund der individualität der
leistungsfälle keine aussagen getroffen
werden
nordfriesland die grenze zu dänemark ist
nur rund 50 kilometer entfernt hier
wohnt und arbeitet
isabel stüler
vor fünf jahren hat sie sich
selbstständig gemacht
als vertriebs trainerin gibt sie
fortbildungen und berät unternehmen
normalerweise durch corona sind die
aufträge im umfang von 16.000 euro
weggebrochen
[Musik]
das hat natürlich auch und totale
tiefpunkte totale verzweiflung bei wanja
auch nicht wusste wie lange begleitet
uns noch kronach gibt es noch eine
zweite welle das essen dann das sind
solche sachen
da ist man teil am ende mit platz vier
hat isabell stühler nicht bekommen
und weil sie geringe betriebskosten hat
darf sie nur einen kleinen teil der
soforthilfe verwenden von der hilfe ist
sie enttäuscht
um das zu ändern versucht sie druck auf
landespolitiker in schleswig holstein zu
machen
auf facebook hat sie sich mit einem
video brief direkt an daniel günther
gewandt dem ministerpräsidenten
dienstleistung unser bundesland effektiv
und nachhaltig unterstützen einfachen
rahmen ein treffen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten kommt nicht zustande
aber ein fdp politiker aus dem landtag
wird aufmerksam
und er organisiert für isabell schüler
tatsächlich einen termin beim
wirtschaftsminister von
schleswig-holstein
kiel für isabell stühler geht es heute
ums ganze sie ist unzufrieden damit wie
die hilfen für solo selbständige
funktionieren
ja ich werde einfach mal unsere lage
schildern die klassische lage von den
selbständigen und ich erwarte mir jetzt
antworten und lösungsvorschläge wie wir
aus dieser dramatischen finanziellen
notsituation rauskommen soll noch nicht
erwartet auf jeden fall finanzielle
unterstützung
rund 75.000 selbstständige gibt es in
schleswig holstein
isabel stühler ist eine davon und sie
will antworten von wirtschaftsminister
bernd buchholz
es gibt daneben auch bedingungen die man
im einzelnen ländern eben auch sorgsam
bis zu ende lesen muss und da haben wir
an vielen stellen festgestellt
das muss man lesen und verstehen aber
darüber reden bedeuten
der minister möchte uns beim gesprächen
nicht dabei haben will den fall
gemeinsam mit isabell stühler
durchgehend eine stunde wird es dauern
das ergebnis angeboten den fall zu
begleiten das mal wirklich genau
durchgerechnet wird was steht denn jetzt
wirklich an soforthilfe zu und was an
der grundsicherung weil da bin ich ja
nach wie vor ratlos und da bekomme ich
unterstützung von einer mitarbeiterin
und hand auf der buchholz und wir werden
das genau aufdröseln und darf da bin ich
schon sehr gespannt auf hilfe vom
minister persönlich die restlichen rund
2,2 millionen solo selbstständigen in
deutschland werden solche unterstützung
wohl eher nicht bekommen die einen teil
der soforthilfe gstaad dass ein teil der
soforthilfe auf die lebenshaltungskosten
aufgewendet wird das wie wird das in
schleswig-holstein gehabt hast wird so
nicht gehandhabt in schleswig holstein
weil es so vom bund nicht vorgesehen ist
aber sie hätten ja auch die möglichkeit
gehabt ja in der tat und dann würde ich
jetzt mit landesmitteln dasitzen und wie
nordrhein westfalen und baden
württemberg mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister darum ringen
die wirtschaftsminister haben alle dafür
geworben dass die solo selbstständigen
mit einem unternehmerlohn bei der
soforthilfe berücksichtigt werden sollen
dafür haben wir alle geworden der bund
hat das definitiv geprüft und abgelehnt
die länder schieben es auf den bund der
bund gibt es auf die länder unter
zwischen stehen solo selbständige wie
isabelle stüler
[Musik]
die auswirkungen von corona treffen
deutschlands wirtschaft mit voller wucht
umso wichtiger ist es dass staatliche
hilfen unkompliziert unbürokratisch und
zielgerichtet sind doch für viele solo
selbständige entpuppen sie sich als
leeres versprechen immer mehr fürchten
um ihre existenz
[Musik]